[Music]
the first look at marvel's werewolf by
night has come out of the shadows here's
why this special presentation has more
going on than you might think
one of the biggest surprises to come out
of marvel studios panel at 2022's d23
event was the release of the werewolf by
night trailer kevin feige revealed this
is the first ever holiday special for
marvel studios and the trailer even
debuted a new intro card we've never
seen before instead of the traditional
marvel studios logo we're used to a
colorful netflix-esque graphic
introduced a special presentation card
with the studio logo above it the
werewolf by night trailer is like
nothing we've ever seen in the marvel
cinematic universe before it's a campy
throwback to the hammer horror films of
old shot entirely in black and white and
creepy as all get out the popcorn flick
will be the mcu's first halloween
special introducing gail garcia bernal's
jack russell aka werewolf by night into
the cinematic universe we met some
classic comic book characters in the
trailer while also being introduced to
brand new players all in this terrifying
gathering of monster hunters there's a
lot to be distracted by in the unusual
trailer so we broke down some of the
small details you might have missed
tonight
it is every hunter for
themselves
a character we weren't quite sure we'd
ever get in the mcu is finally here man
thing who made his marvel studios debut
in the werewolf finite trailer in a
blink and you'll miss it moment dr ted
salas first appeared in 1971's savage
tales number one and is one of marvel
comics most unusual characters dr salus
becomes man thing after injecting
himself with his so2 serum a failed
super soldier serum replica and crashing
his car into a part of the florida
everglades that just happens to be the
nexus of all realities you can clearly
see man thing at the 105 mark in the
trailer where he looks to be melting a
combatant manthing does have connections
to werewolf in the comics as both were
members of the legion of monsters
whether that group forms in the holiday
special remains to be seen but the team
also includes elsa bloodstone who is
featured in the werewolf by night
trailer heavily at least we think it
hasn't been officially confirmed at this
point but it's almost a 99 certainty
that outlander star laura donnelly is
playing elsa bloodstone in werewolf by
night the daughter of ulysses bloodstone
elsa is a master monster hunter who
often favors firearms as her weapons of
choice despite that history the woman we
see in the trailer seems much more timid
than the elsa fans of the comics know
and love donnelly's character seems to
cower around jack russell when he's
transforming into the werewolf in front
of her in the cage this could be just a
put on or maybe it's a part of the
character's development on screen either
way here's hoping we'll see elsa turn
into the badass she's known to be in the
marvel's comic pages the film's black
and white appearance makes elsa's hair
look like it's a dark brown or black but
it's definitely possible she's sporting
her comic variants bright red locks
somewhere beneath the special shades of
grey some characters don't quite fit in
with the theme of werewolf by night
sticking out like sore thumbs outside of
the creepy and spooky monster hunters we
see gathering at varus's behest there
are uniformed outsiders who appear to be
crashing the party those uniforms look
awfully familiar they sort of look like
time variants authority agents as seen
in loki season 1 however it's worth
noting that the uniforms are not a 100
match so this could be another one of
those classic misdirections from our
friends at marvel these agents were
tasked with capturing variants and those
who disrupt the sacred timeline it's
suspected that werewolf by night takes
place in the past and we think they
might be crashing the monster mesh in
search of the darkhold that is if that
really is the tva there is precedent for
that from the comics the sacred text
first makes an appearance in marvel
spotlight volume one number four which
centered around a werewolf by night
story jack russell finds the dark hold
which we know is extremely dangerous in
the mcu thanks in no small part to the
scarlet witch it makes sense the tva
would intervene anywhere that darkhold
might be present as wanda recently
demonstrated bad actors in pursuit of
the book can connect to alternate selves
in other timelines making them a major
threat for the tva
[Music]